[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Hi, everybody.
Welcome to Google Talks.
Today's a very special day.
I want to introduce a great
friend of mine and somebody
that I really look
up to in tech space.
His name is Arnell Milhouse.
What makes him unique
and very special
is he has led many
hackathons in Rhode Island,
has been recognized by
President Obama, and Congress
men and women.
Aside from that,
the beautiful thing
is that he's helped today
lead many underprivileged and
underserved markets for people
that are interested in becoming
engineers.
Aside from that,
he is constantly
challenging the
status quo and always
making sure that many people
are involved and challenged
every day in a very
technological, digital age.
I'd love to welcome my dearest
friend and a leader in tech
and a serial entrepreneur,
Arnell Milhouse.
[APPLAUSE]
ARNELL MILHOUSE: Thank
you, [INAUDIBLE].
Appreciate it.
Thanks for having me.
It's been great to be here.
All right, so good
afternoon, everyone.
Again, my name is
Arnell Milhouse.
And it's an interesting story
and an interesting journey
that we're embarking upon.
And today we're going to
be talking about rebooting
emerging domestic markets.
This concept was first spoken
about three or four decades ago
by a Harvard University
professor who
talked about taking urban
centers and the taking
the underserved workers
in those communities,
training them, giving them the
right technical skills or labor
skills that they needed to
integrate into society here
in America.
He wrote a really
great book about it,
but the concept never
really took off.
And throughout my
life as I grew up,
in the story that
I'm about to share,
I always thought about how can
we really make this happen?
How can we take it from the
page and put it on the stage,
as they often say
on Broadway, right,
from the page to the stage.
And I'm even writing
a book about it,
"Rebooting the Emerging
Domestic Markets,
Re-architecting the Middle Class
Innovation Process in America."
And I'm an entrepreneur,
a software developer.
But I really think of
myself as a social change
agent, someone who's trying to
bring about change and impact.
Steve Jobs talked
about, of all the things
that he wanted to
do in his life,
he simply wanted to make
a dent in the universe.
And it wasn't about the money.
It wasn't about the
creations or the accolades.
It was about making
a significant change.
And so I created a company
called IntraCity Geeks,
along with a couple
of other gentlemen,
I'll be introducing
them by name.
And another organization
called CareerDevs.
IntraCity Geeks, our goal is
to simply fuel computer science
education into drive, innovation
driven entrepreneurship
throughout American cities
in both underserved and
underskilled markets.
Our main goal is to impact
1 million plus people
in our pipeline.
The organization is
called CareerDevs,
and CareerDevs is launching
rigorous computer science
academies along with
innovation driven
entrepreneurial incubators.
So while IntraCity Geeks
is the nonprofit arm,
CareerDevs is the
for profit arm.
How all this stuff
comes together--
you really need to take a
deep dive into my story.
And it's a really
interesting story, I believe.
It starts off back in
Boston, Massachusetts,
where I was born.
I was born to a single
mother, Dorothy Lee Milhouse,
and single mom, which is really
the prototypical urban story
that you hear for
people of color, right?
And my mother had four
children, which one is me?
Can you guys guess?
That's me right
there, second oldest.
And what was interesting
in Boston that--
we went from a middle
class neighborhood--
my mother ended up getting sick.
We moved from a middle class
neighborhood to a lower income
neighborhood after she took ill.
And while Roxbury, which was a
neighborhood that we moved to,
was very, very tough--
there was gunfire, drug needles,
I've had guns held to my head,
coming from school, people
robbing me for money.
I would get home, my mother
like, how was your day, honey?
I'm like, oh, it was fine.
So a couple of things
were interesting.
One, we didn't know
that we were poor.
And we didn't know that--
I didn't know that
we should be unhappy.
We were happy.
We had a nice family.
But one day, my mother-- when
we were on welfare, food stamps,
Section 8 housing--
she took her housing certificate
to the housing authorities
and said she wanted to move.
And they were asking her,
where do you want to move?
And she mentioned that she
wanted to move to Cape Cod,
right?
And it wasn't until we
actually moved to Cape Cod,
that I noticed this.
That the urban lifestyle
formula that we
had been living, that there was
a vicious perpetuating cycle
that repeated itself.
So in eighth grade,
we packed up.
We moved to Cape Cod.
And it was, you
know, this is a place
that people travel to
for vacations from all
around the world, and I'm
living there 365 days a year.
But I noticed another cycle a
virtuous perpetuating cycle,
which was the opposite of what
was taking place in Boston.
And for the first time in
my life, something changed--
my world view.
Because living in
Boston and Cape Cod,
the dichotomy was
incredibly different.
On the Cape, I
was taking courses
such as Latin, where I learned
one of my favorite jokes--
[SPEAKING LATIN]
Where are your underwear?
We even had a rap for Latin.
Latin is a dead language.
It's dead as it can be.
First it killed the Romans,
and now it's killing me.
[SPEAKING LATIN]
And so I'm learning all
these different things.
And when we moved
to the Cape, we
didn't live in
tenement buildings
that you found in the city.
We lived right off the 7th
hole of the Dennis Pines Golf
Course.
And I remember waking
up one morning,
I saw all these little
white balls in my yard.
And I said, Mom,
why are these balls
keep coming into our yard?
And what are those
people out there doing?
What are they--
are they farming?
It looks like they're
trying to farm.
What are they planting?
I couldn't understand it.
She was, no, honey,
they're playing golf.
I said, what is golf?
And I learned about
Camelot, the Kennedys.
They lived 10 minutes from me,
the Kennedy compound, John F.
Kennedy, his family,
everyone, their lineage.
So I heard the story.
I was regaled with
all of the tales
of their fame and their
wealth, and it was just
a different
perspective of learning
about a former president,
that their family lived down
the street.
The next stage was
kind of interesting.
My first job in high school
took place at a place
called Fred's Turkey House.
Now this is really impactful.
Because I started
off as a dishwasher,
then a prep cook, then a
line cook, then a chef.
But at this restaurant,
the person that owned it,
his name was Fred Blum,
one of my greatest mentors
and influences in my life.
He had about four or five
restaurants on the Cape.
And there was a gentleman that
went to Harvard University that
graduated in computer science
who worked for him, running
all of the communications.
Jeff Rule, he was
talking about trying
to lure me to the dark side,
which is computer science.
Because Arnell, because you
don't want to be a laborer,
sweating away in a
kitchen all your life.
He goes, listen,
you know, you love
playing around with
computers and making
these video games in school.
Stick with that.
And so I said, uh.
But then Fred said, hey, no,
listen, go to Johnson and Wales
University, come back here
and manage my restaurants.
So there was a light side
and a dark side tempting me.
Then in high school, I took
my first computer programming
class, Pascal, fell in love.
Myself and several
other students,
we were always getting in
trouble, doing things with code
that you shouldn't be doing.
And then I got a job
working for my high school,
making $12 an hour as a junior.
I was hooked.
I was making more than I
was making in the restaurant
business, and it
was just phenomenal.
Something else interesting
that that happened on the Cape
was, one of my teachers was
asking where I lived in Boston.
I said, oh, I remember
living, we once
lived on Mass Ave,
Massachusetts Avenue.
And she said, oh, you were
right down the street from MIT.
I said M I what?
M I who?
She goes no, MIT, Ivy
League university?
Never heard of it.
She goes, it was less than
a quarter mile from you.
And that really bothered me.
That MIT and Harvard
were so close,
but they might as well have
been miles away, planets away,
different universe, really.
Going to school on
the Cape, students
would pull up in the school in
BMWs, Mercedes, or just brand
new cars, brand new Toyotas.
When our car, even though
we lived on the Cape,
it was still--
we were still poor.
We were using a
housing certificate
to live on Cape Cod.
So sometimes dropping
us off at school--
we had this station wagon
that had mismatched wheels,
smoke coming out
of the back of it.
And so I would beg
my mom, can you
please, can you drop
me off down the street?
She goes, honey, but it's
still like a quarter mile walk.
I was just embarrassed to pull
up in the school in that car.
What was happening was that I
was experiencing culture shock.
I was seriously
undergoing a sense
of disorientation and disbelief
about what I was seeing.
My middle school, the
cafeteria was more reminiscent
of what you have here.
In Boston, we didn't
have a cafeteria.
Everything was makeshift, and
the food wasn't that great.
Periodically, we would travel
back and forth to Boston.
And I began to see this
divergence between my cousins'
lives and my friends' lives,
my friends and their parents
on the Cape versus my friends
and their parents in Boston.
As I was in Boston,
I would notice
the adults were talking
about how hard things
were, that there were
no opportunities.
They just lost their job.
They couldn't get ahead.
Their electricity was
being turned off this week.
On the Cape,
everything was happy,
and everyone was doing fine.
And as we would
go back and forth
it was lights on, lights off.
Lights on, lights off,
it was disconcerting.
And I didn't know--
I said-- and Boston and
Cape Cod, 60 miles apart.
So it really, really, really
troubled me, back and forth,
Cape Cod, Boston,
Cape Cod to Boston.
And I remember the exact moment
that this thing happened.
I woke up one morning, and I
realized I had two world views.
Because of my friends
in Boston, they all,
and myself included, when I
initially moved to Cape Cod,
I wanted to be a rapper,
basketball player, or some type
of athlete or entertainer.
Where everyone in
the Cape was talking
about where we're
going to school,
what we're going to
do with our careers.
And so hearing two
different worlds,
two different world
views, and I saw
that one world view
was just crumbling
and the other was thriving.
So I left high school, and
I went to college at Johnson
and Wales University,
computer science, much
like my buddy Cliff.
And at Johnson and Wales,
things really took off.
I was a computer lab assistant.
And that's when I
learned about innovation.
I started taking some of
the processes that they
had in place that
took four or five
days to change
the computers over
at the end of each semester,
and I brought it down
to a three hour process.
And my bosses were freaking out.
They were like, oh, my
goodness, this is amazing.
And there were a
lot of other things
that I did that really, really
impacted the University.
Something really, really
bad happened though
my freshman year.
My mother passed away.
All those years of being sick,
[INAUDIBLE] she passed away.
My younger brother and younger
sister, my older brother,
myself-- we had to try to figure
out what are we going to do.
My older brother said,
you stay in school,
work hard, send money
home on the weekends.
And I did that.
In my sophomore year, I
became a senior lab assistant
at Johnson Wales, which meant
I received free tuition, which
really saved me.
Because the school
was sending me notices
that you have no money,
you can't stay in school.
And I graduated Johnson Wales
and something interesting
happened.
The second job that
I had was in Boston.
And when I was on
the Cape, my mother
would tell me all the time,
pay attention, Arnell.
I brought you down here so
that you could pay attention
to find out how people
are becoming successful.
In family after family,
what does your father do?
Oh, he's into technology.
Again, there was Jeff
at Fred's Turkey House.
Arnell, come to the dark side.
But every family seemed
to have some connection
to some type of technical
organization working in Boston.
So I said, I'm going to
apply to a job in Boston.
I applied for this data
telecommunications company,
walked into the company.
Another shock-- I
walked in, and I
was the only person of color
within the entire organization.
And I said, they're
not going to hire me.
I'm like, there's no way.
But I become really
good at what I do,
with technology,
computer science.
So I got an offer
letter in the mail.
And it was for $80,000.
And it was the second time that
I was shocked, culture shock.
The company, much
like here at Google--
cafeteria, food, chefs coming
in, massage therapists.
I didn't know that it
was leading up to this.
$80,000 a year, $15,000 annual
bonus, 15,000 shares of stock,
what is stock?
Stock, what is stock?
Is that like Campbell's stock?
I didn't know.
Are they going to send me
15,000 cans of Campbell's stock?
I don't want that.
But it was culture
shock, round two.
Something else hit me.
I was no longer poor.
And it was welcome
to the middle class.
But I think, as hard as
it was making it there,
if I had known that it was
going to be that difficult,
I probably would have given up.
But since I had
made it this far,
I said, why stop at
the middle class?
Why not keep on going?
What's the next
exit have in store?
So something interesting
started happening.
My friends, family, and
neighbors started noticing.
Oh, Arnell has some
new clothes, new car,
living in a nice house.
So people were peaking,
and then people
started knocking at my
door, especially my friends.
I have a friend that
was in the Marines.
And he came up to me,
says Arnell, listen,
I just got in the Marines.
It's all I need to
do is shoot a gun.
What do I do?
I got him involved
in technology.
And then after him--
his name is Jason,
he's African-American;
another friend of mine,
Rick, Jamaican background;
Hov, Cambodian; Tim,
Irish-American; Dave, English;
OC, Latino.
Tim, Kevin, Derek, Sam, Charlie,
Lynn, John, Mike, Will, Jeff,
Chuck, Devin, Pete, Rob, Kurt--
so many other
people that started
coming to me and my friends
to get involved in technology.
People who were on welfare,
unemployed, or severely
underemployed, overall
about 25 people
who now have an
aggregate annual income
of over two million dollars.
And if you look at the
majority of those people,
all got married, all own homes.
And so that cycle that my
mother was caught up in,
so many other people were
caught in, single mother,
no father in the household--
was now being broken in
so many people's lives.
And so many children,
including myself,
my two amazing sons right here
and my amazing wife, who I
would not be here without.
And so I started
thinking, again,
how do we solve the
income inequality puzzle?
And the solution is simple.
We have to do it at
scale, and that's
where I really began
thinking about the rebooting
emerging domestic markets.
So I had my great moment
of epiphany, seen it,
what all of my
friends had attained.
And then over the
past few years,
looking at all of the
pain that this country has
been going through with the
battles between race and income
and the haves and the
have nots, I said,
what I've done for
my friends, I simply
need to do for the
rest of the country.
That's easy, right, no problem.
So I started a company
called IntraCity Geeks.
It's a nonprofit.
And something
interesting happened.
I put an ad up on Brown
University's website,
and this double major,
[INAUDIBLE] econ brainiac
named Rapolas Binkys applied.
I sit down with him, blew me
away with his intelligence.
He worked with me, getting
the organization going.
And then I met
another gentleman.
And he's here today
in the audience.
His name is Cliff, brainiac.
We've seen like the
Superman comics, Brainiac?
That's Cliff right there.
And we'll talk a
little more about that.
But at IntraCity
Geeks, we started
teaching at the middle
school level in Providence.
And it got picked up
in the news, like wow,
this is really cool.
No one has done this before,
or at least not at the scale
that we were looking
to run our programs.
We were on Channel 10.
We were taking students to
hackathons at Brown University.
And they were growing.
They were doing amazing
things with themselves.
In the red shirt here, you
can see my son Matthias.
He actually teaches with me now.
He's a lead instructor for
elementary school students.
He's 14 years old,
eighth grader-- actually,
not 14 yet, in a few
weeks, he's going to be.
But he's doing amazing things.
And again, that
generational stronghold,
that generational
change affect, having
a father figure, a mother
figure that's nurturing him,
to help him grow.
And Elias is coming up
behind, learning as well.
So we went from middle
schools to high schools,
teaching, talking about how
they can get jobs in technology.
$72,000 is the average of the
jobs paying in Rhode Island.
The mayor of Providence
contacted us and said, hey,
you're doing some great things.
What can we do together?
So we created a hackathon
for the city of Providence.
And not just any
hackathon, but we were also
recognized by President
Obama for our work.
It was on the White House
website, August 4th, 2015.
The culture shock is
continuing to happen.
I'm seeing the vision fulfilled
of what we're trying to do.
And for one of the
hackathons that we did--
what we attempted to
do, we built a satellite
communications
array to communicate
with the astronauts in the
International Space Station
as it flew overhead,
over Providence.
The astronauts were
sleeping, but we
did get a ping connection
signal with our device.
But we've stressed to the
students-- when we did this,
we partnered with a group
from Brown University,
middle school students
and high school students,
who assembled the communications
array, designed it,
and got it working--
this is the type of
innovation that we
want to let students
know is possible.
And they're like, now
they go out there,
they have the apps
on their phone.
I get calls from students
all the time, hey,
I'm looking at the International
Space Station going up
overhead.
I'm following them
on Twitter, right?
And they're talking
about engineering.
They're talking
about aeronautics.
These are the
impacts and changes
that you want to make everyone
can't move to Cape Cod.
After that, the
governor of Rhode Island
got in contact with us through
her innovation department,
and we created a
hackathon for the state.
I also taught a Harvard computer
science class called cs50
in Rhode Island.
Over 500 people applied.
We enrolled 150.
And cs50 is rooted in the C
programming language-- data
structures, algorithms,
computational thinking,
strong, strong rigor.
And it was during that course,
and here's a snapshot of it,
that's my head there.
I'll give you that same view.
But during that class,
I met one student that
approached me halfway through.
Everyone was two or
three weeks behind.
Except for one student, who
comes up to me, and says,
I'm finished with the course.
I said you can't be.
That was Cliff.
Toward the end of the class,
Harvard had a global computer
comp coding competition, and
Cliff's team was only one
of 13 that finished
with a perfect score out
of 630 something teams
worldwide, perfect score.
I was impressed.
We began to hang
out a little bit,
and Cliff became my third geek
crush that I had in my life.
The first was Jeff Rule
from Fred's Turkey House,
the second was Rapolas,
and then Cliff.
So from there, we
formed CareerDevs.
And CareerDevs is
the for profit arm.
We're launching a computer
science training academy
this summer.
We're teaching people in Rhode
Island, New York and Boston
rigorous computer science.
We were just in
Brooklyn two weeks ago.
We're coming back again in May.
And there are 36 schools
in the five boroughs
that are interested in having
CareerDevs do work there--
same in Boston, same
in Rhode Island.
So we're expanding rapidly.
In addition, the way that we're
going to do computer science
is different than at boot camps.
We don't call it a
computer science boot
camp, because the students
are really going to--
too oftentimes, when we
see students graduating
from boot camps, they can't
do anything significant
when they complete the course.
So we want to make sure that
there's a lot of testing
and a lot of rigor and ideation.
At every stage, we
want to make sure
that there's a creation
portion that they
can reiterate, and from recall,
do examples that they create.
It's really, really
important, plus the focus
on data structures
and algorithms,
which Cliff is a Jedi knight.
Or would that be a Sith,
since we are on the dark side?
Probably a Sith.
The other thing
that's interesting
is that I've had several
entrepreneurial journeys
over the years.
And a couple of years ago,
I created a organization
called CrowdSigned.
And I applied to one
of the big incubators.
And I thought, wow, they're
going to love my idea.
And they rejected me.
I didn't have an
understanding of metrics,
total addressable market space.
There were a lot of things
I didn't understand.
So I had to hit the books.
One of my friends
said, oh, go up to MIT.
They're having this of
course on entrepreneurship.
So I went up there, registered,
sat in on it, learned a ton.
Like, oh, Bill Aulet,
he has this great book.
You should check it out,
"Disciplined Entrepreneurship."
So I internalized that.
And as I've done that,
several other people
have come to me now saying they
want some entrepreneurial help
with their products.
In the same way that I helped my
friends learning about computer
science, I'm now helping people
learn about entrepreneurship.
So Cliff and myself, we're
going to be also teaching
about entrepreneurship.
And as CareerDevs launches,
two of the companies
that we're highlighting--
one is called Common Connect.
It allows you to
connect with people
as you would with
LinkedIn professionally,
but socially, based
upon your location.
How many times
are you traveling,
you're walking past someone
on Eighth or Ninth or 16th,
that you could probably
have a lot of synergy with,
but you don't know that person.
Now with Common
Connect in your pocket,
when you're passing that
person, you'll know.
And since you're in
the same vicinity,
you'll be able to connect.
Another one is
called CrowdSigned,
informed analytics that
help drive the market
for unsigned artists.
So it's data driven, analytic
driven, innovative IP
behind both of these companies
that we're launching.
And Cliff's the lead
developer on both of those.
So what's our vision?
It's the same thing that
happened with my friends.
But instead of people
now, we're also
looking at
corporations, companies.
The difference being not
just starting a business,
but what's a scalable,
innovation driven,
IP portfolio driven
incubator look
like that's designed
for the underskilled
and the underserved?
Because I've been convinced
by Bill Aulet and people
from Brown University
like Dan Warshay--
anyone can learn
entrepreneurship.
And anyone can learn
computer science
if they apply
themselves long enough,
if they hack at it long enough.
And so our goal is to create
this multiplier, this network
multiplier that will
really bring upon this era
where we can reboot emerging
domestic markets here
in this country.
And so over time, stay
tuned, and thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
If you are interested in
getting contact with us
or following our story,
you can follow along
on IntraCityGeeks.org,
CareerDevs.com,
and you can email
Cliff, myself as noted.
Thanks once again.
[APPLAUSE]
So we're going to take
a couple of questions.
If anyone has any questions,
they can feel free to ask them.
Or if you're interested
in working for us
and leaving Google.
[LAUGHTER]
Yes, and we have
microphones over there.
So we're going to have each
person stand up at a microphone
to ask their questions.
AUDIENCE: Throughout all of
the struggles that you've
faced with two different
cities, moving back and forth,
what kept you so motivated to
continue to go from the lower
class to middle class
to now being, obviously,
a very wealthy individual?
ARNELL MILHOUSE: I
don't know if I would
say very wealthy individual.
But-- I took an Uber
here this morning.
Don't have a chauffeur.
But my motivation was--
you know it's interesting.
So here's an interesting
story that from Cape Cod.
I remember once being out in the
ocean with some of my friends.
You know, one of my
friends said hey,
let's swim out to
my father's boat.
It was that type of situation.
So we're swimming out to what we
thought was his father's boat.
And he told us, he was joking.
He goes this isn't
my father's boat.
It's that one out there.
It's much further away.
And so in that situation
there, you just
keep swimming because
you have to swim.
And as I made it one
mile or past one goal,
I just kept going,
and I kept swimming.
And then once, like
I said, because when
I made it to the middle class.
I said, OK, well,
I did this now.
And even though it's hard
work, I'm going to keep going.
Because I look back at a
lot of my friends and family
that were in Boston.
Everyone's working
hard, whether you're
a lower class, middle
class, or upper class,
everyone has a pretty
hard life in terms
of the hours that
you have to put in
and things of that nature.
So I'd rather work hard
to bring about success
and also try to bring
people along with me.
So it's just--
I've never really
thought about why.
So to answer your
question, I don't know.
But it's just something
you don't give up.
You just can't give up.
And I know that I had my
younger brother and sister.
That was a great motivating
factor for me as well.
And then once they were set,
I had friends and family
that came along.
And you know, you
always see needs.
And I guess you see needs and
needs that need to be met,
and you go for it.
Thank you.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: Thanks for
sharing your story.
I really appreciate
it, very inspiring.
ARNELL MILHOUSE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: You talked about how
the goal with IntraCity Geeks
is to help inner city
middle youth make
the jump to middle class
through technology jobs.
Have you considered looking into
other professions, like law,
medicine, finance,
and other professions
for people who might
not find themselves
very attuned to technology?
ARNELL MILHOUSE: Yes, and I
believe that will be the goal.
But like with most things,
when you're starting something,
you can only do one thing well.
You can only do one thing well.
And for instance, Google started
off doing just a search engine.
And now you guys are doing
a couple of other things
in addition to search, right?
And so yes, but we
do want to expand
to bring more people into that.
Because not everyone is going
to be a programmer or a network
engineer.
AUDIENCE: Right.
ARNELL MILHOUSE:
Yeah, thank you.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So thank you
for taking the time
and sharing your story.
So what is success
for IntraCity Geeks?
And what do you guys want
to accomplish over time?
ARNELL MILHOUSE: So success for
IntraCity Geeks and CareerDevs
is pretty large.
I always ask the question and
it seems crazy when I hear it.
When I hear the goal in
my head, it sounds crazy.
But when you think of John F.
Kennedy standing up and saying
in that New England accent--
we're going to-- by
the end of this decade,
we're going to put one
man on the moon, right?
Or you look at the
accomplishments of individuals
and companies, such as
Google, self-driving cars,
the work that's being done
with TensorFlow and machine
learning, and just all the
advances that that's bringing
about, my goal is to--
and it's been talked
about so much--
but I really believe
that in America we
can set the example for having
balanced income equality.
Not everyone is going to
be a Jeff Bezos or Larry
Page or a Bill Gates.
But you don't have to have
large swaths of our society
that are living in squalor.
I believe that we can--
and the impact that
people have that
are underserved
and underskilled--
they can contribute to the might
of the American economic engine
to make us an even stronger
and greater country.
And that's not just
for urban markets.
But that's also for
suburban markets.
The principal from
my high school
says, Arnell, we need you
to come here to the Cape.
Because we have those pockets
of underskilled people here.
And so it's not
just an urban thing.
It's not just a black thing or
a Latino thing or a white thing.
There are poor people
everywhere in this country.
And that's my goal.
My goal is to create
balanced income equality.
Well, thanks once again.
I really appreciate the
opportunity of being here.
And we'll see you next time.
[APPLAUSE]